عن الموقف الامريكيه المعبر عنه من قبل
الخارجيه الامريكيه مواصفته بالقلق هي لما
وصفتها بالاستفزاز معنا من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره ناصر الحسين ناصر ماذا عن هذا
الموقف عن المتابعه الامريكيه حيال وصفته
بالاستفزاز وغير القانوني يتعلق
بالمستوطنه
نعم منذ فتره والولايات المتحده الصامته
حقيقه على ما يجري في الاراضي المقدسه على
ما يحدث يوميا فيما يخص الاحتلال
وتداعياته واحداثه وتفاصيله وراينا حتى في
الفتره الاخيره عندما كانت اسرائيل تقصف
اهدافها العسكريه المدنيه كانت الولايات
المتحده الصامته هو ان صدر من بيان فكان
الموقف الامريكي ان اسرائيل تدافع عن
نفسها ولا الحق في الدفاع عن النفس كان
هذا قبل ايام فقط الان في واشنطن تغيرت
النبره لنقل في الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
الخارجيه الامريكيه اصدرت بيانا شديدا
اللهجه الى حد ما بالمقاييس الامريكيه
يعبر اولا عن الانزعاج الشديد وايضا الرفض
التام لما يحدث على الارض من طرف بعض
الوزراء المحسوبين على الجهات اليمنيه
المتطرفه بشكل خاص وموجه وبحديث مباشر الى
اسرائيل وسلطاتها وساستها الخارجه
الامريكيه قالت صراحه انها ترفض مثلا هذا
ذلك من السلوك السياسي من الزيارات التي
تعتبرها استفزازيه لبن غفير للحرم القدسي
والاقصى لانه لان ذلك لا يساعد وقالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه بوضوح في بيانها انها
قلقه من هذه الزياره التي وصفتها بالزياره
الاستفزازيه التي تمت يوم الاحد الوزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول وتذكر المنطقه
ايضا والاسرائيليين خاص انه لا يجوز لا
يسمح لهذا النوع من الاستخدام السياسي كما
تقول للمواقع المقدسه للاغراض السياسيه
وتعود واشنطن لتذكر الجميع في المنطقه
بانها تدعو جميع الاطراف في خضم صراعتها
الى احترام قدسيتها هذا المواقع المهم
ايضا ان الخارجيه الامريكيه تشير الى
ضروره احترام ايضا الدور الاردني في كل
هذا ان هناك الاردن الذي كما تقول خارجيه
الامريكيه ما زال وصيا ويسهر على تلك
الاراضي
تلك البقع المقدسه لدى الديانات الثلاث
وبالتالي يجب احترام هذا الدور حقيقه
الاهميه في هذا البيان الامريكي انه تحدث
ولم يعد نوعا من الحديث الهاطفي الصامت
نوع من الضغوط على اسرائيل وراء الستار
لكن الان لدينا بيان امريكي يعبر عن موقف
امريكي رسمي يوجه لاسرائيل بوجه خاص ولكن
ايضا للشركاء العرب في المنطقه
في هذه اللحظه ان فهمت جيدا فهي رساله
تحذير في الحقيقه الى الاصدقاء في اسرائيل
وانه حان الوقت ربما لمراجعه ذلك النوع من
السلوك من بعض الشخصيات المثيره للجدل في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما ترى الامور هنا
واشنطن واشنطن تعتبر ان ذلك النوع من
السلوك يمكن ان يؤدي بطبيعه الحال الى
الكثير من الامور قد تنتهي بعض الاحيان
الى امور عسكريه هذا الخوف هذا الانزعاج
هذا هو تذكير للموقف الامريكي من جهه ولكن
ايضا تذكير للحكومه بان عليها واجبات يجب
ان تستمر فيها ان ارادت استمرار الدعم
الامريكي الوزاره الامريكيه ايضا وهي
تتحدث عن بن غفير وزيارته للاقصى وكل ما
تحمل من معنى ومن خطاب تحريضي كما تقول
المتحده تشد تنزعج وتقول ولايه ايضا في
مساله المستوطنات وكيف الان اسرائيل
تتراجع عن الضمانات التي قدمتها للولايات
المتحده بعدم وضع شكرا عدم
شكرا لك واعتذر منك كنت معنا من واش